we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is troy
york using one of his very poorly
disguised voices claiming that he knows
the real voter suppression that's going
on and he doesn't think i'm telling you
about it why don't you have a program
about voter suppression through the use
of polls and fake polls and fake polling
carried swords getting people to think
that their votes don't matter is that it
nope this is the reason we don't have
thankfully a dictator like another
Hitler like Hillary Clinton as president
this is a very confused individual I do
shows about voter suppression all the
time but let me tell you Troy or whoever
this guy is about the real voter
suppression the real voter suppression
is requiring forms of ID that while free
to obtain require you to have documents
that aren't free the real voter
suppression is removing people from
voter rolls the real voter suppression
is reducing voting hours and early
voting strategically in places that have
disproportionately democratic vote am I
making myself clear like that's the real
voter suppression the problem is Troy
York isn't making himself clear like
this you just want one episode of the
David Pakman show dedicated to this yes
or does he want an entirely new program
called like the fake polls show like
who's gonna pick that up no station's
gonna run that no we would it would be a
self-destructive it would be more
self-inflicted than Trump's tweets about
the Russia investigation if we converted
this into the voter suppression show
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we are going to talk about why the
United States ranks at the bottom in a
foreign aid index very interesting and
potentially deceptive not deceptive but
confusing to some unusual results we'll
talk about that also there is this story
that has blown up about FanDuel saying
that it is not going to honor
huge payouts after what they claimed was
a technical error and there are a lot of
people who are simply not buying that
explanation those stories and more on
today's bonus show two ways to get
access to it number one become a member
at WWE at medCom number two become a
patron at atleast the $5 a month level
patreon.com slash david pakman show
speak to you in just a few seconds on
the bonus show